الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلنت سلطات شبه جزيره القرم المواليه
لروسيا اسقاط ثلاثه صواريخ في منطقه مضيق
كيرج ونفت السلطات وقوع اي اضرار في جسر
القرمه واشارت الى ان حركه المرور عبر
الجسر اوقفت مؤقتا وستستانف في اقرب وقت
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت ان شبه
جزيره القرم ومقاطعتي كالوجا الروسيتين
تعرضت لهجمات بطائرات مسيره اوكرانيه دون
وقوع اصابات معنى من دنيتك مراسل الجزيره
نور الدين ومن اودسم مراسل الجزيره عامر
لافي نور الدين الابرز هو ربما اذا
استهداف جسر القرم مره اخرى هذه طبعا ليست
المره المره الاولى ولا الثانيه ولا
الثالثه
نعم عثمان ما يمكن نقله كاخر خبر لحد
الساعه وهو اعلان السلطات في شبه جزيره
القرم عن اعاده العمل
بجسر الكرم بعدما تم اغلاقه خلال الفتره
السابقه بمعنى اخر بان حاجز الخوف والهلع
الذي كان هناك وكذلك حاجز الخطر الذي كانت
تتوقعه السلطات بوصول قذائف صاروخيه الى
تلك المنطقه قد انتفى وبالتالي عوده
الحركه بشكل سلس الى جسر القرمه كنا قد
اسلفنا في وقت سابق على ان الاغلاق
المفاجئ الذي حدث للمره الثانيه هذا اليوم
كانت هناك دواعي ربما كانت دواعي امنيه
وهو ما تبين بعد ذلك كان هناك استهداف
صاروخي مره اخرى بنفس الصاروخ الذي استهدف
به الجسر قبل ذلك وهو من نوع اس 200 لكن
تم اعتراضه من قبل السلطات من قبل القوات
الدفاع الجوي الروسي واسقاط هذا الصاروخ
الحديث الروسي الان عن عدم وجود اي خسائر
سواء على المستوى المادي او المستوى
البشري باعتبار ان هذه الصواريخ تم
اعتراضها من قبل القوات الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه بكل تاكيد اليوم شبه جزيره القرم
كانت الموضوع الاساس وربما المحطه
الرئيسيه للهجمات الاوكرانيه صباح هذا
اليوم ما يقارب من عشرين مسيره استهدت
حاولت استهدافها لكن تم اسقاط العشرون
مسيره من قبل قوات الدفاع الجوي بعد ذلك
هجمات صاروخيه يبدو ان الاستراتيجيه هي
محاوله الضغط على روسيا في هذا المكان لكن
يمكن ان نقرا هذا التحرك العسكري
الاوكراني برد الفعل السياسي من هنا من
موسكو عبر الخارجيه الايراني عبر الخارجي
الروسيه التي تتحدث على ان نددت بهذا
الهجوم وقالت بان هذا الهجوم لن يبقى دون
رد باعتبار ان منشاه الجزر هي منشاه مدنيه
وليست منشاه عسكريه وبالتالي لا يمكن
استهدافها استهدافها لكن حينما يتم الحديث
على ان روسيا سترد على هذا الهجوم بكل
تاكيد هنا المنطق والعمل سين الى المؤسسه
العسكريه التي تتحدث عن رد وعن استهداف
المناطق المتوقعه دائما السؤال عثمان ما
هي المناطق المتوقعه للاستهداف بكل تاكيد
المناطق التي انطلقت منها الصواريخ
المناطق التي انطلقت منها المسيرات ومناطق
الدمع الدعم
وكذلك مناطق تجميع المسيرات وبالتالي كل
هذه الاهداف قد تكون اهداف مقبله لهجمات
قد تنفذها القوات الجوده في الجوف فضائيه
الروسيه سواء عبر الصواريخ او عبر
المسيرات ربما قد تكون في اوديسا ربما قد
تكون في كييف او غربه تلك المنطقه اذا
كانت سنتمنى بعيدا عن عامر لافي الموجود
في عامر انت تتابع عندما عدنا الى موضوع
استهداف جسر القرن طبعا يعني قد لا يكون
هناك تصريحات بشكل واضح حول هذا الاستهداف
ولكن في ذات الوقت هناك احتفاء بهذا الامر
بالفعل العثماني هناك احتفاء من وسائل
الاعلام وتصريحات ربما يعني توم بان
اوكرانيا هي التي تقف وراء ما جرى بالنسبه
طبعا الخطر يزال قائما لماذا عثمان لانه
هي المتهمه بانها المسؤوله عن هذه الهجمات
والسفن الاسطول الحربي الروسي رابطه في
البحر الاسود خلفي في حاله تاهب قصوى وفقا
لما ذكرته قياده القوات البحريه كما ذكرنا
بالنسبه للتصريحات لا يوجد تصريحات رسميه
تحدثنا مع قياده القوات البحريه قالوا لنا
لا تعليق حتى الان لكن ربما اللافت
والمقطع الفيديو التي نشرته المخابرات
الاوكرانيه قبل قليل على صفحتها ومع تعليق
مقتضب قالت فيه سنستمر في تدمير الغزات
الروس جوا وبحرا وارضا لكن دون التوضيح اي
شيء اخر لكن المقطع حمل الكثير من صور
الاستهداف بواسطه المسيرات البحريه
والمسيرات قويه واضح انها كثير منها في
البحر وفهمت هنا على انها تعليق على
استهداف جسر القرن اليوم اما بخصوص
استهداف شبه جزيره القرم صباح اليوم فانك
التعليق رسمي من المتحدث باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب نتاليا ومنيوك التي قالت
تعليقا على ما قالته السلطات الروسيه
بينها اسقطت هذه الطائرات قالت هذه
التصريحات هي الاستهلاك المحلي ودائما
السلطات الروسيه تبالغ في انها هذه
المسيرات لا تضرب اهدافها وقالت ايضا بان
موسم استهداف شبه جزيره القرم سيستمر
وحاله الاضطراب في شبه جزيره القرب ستستمر
حتى تتحرر شبه جزيره القرم اذا تصريح واضح
وبالمناسبه طبعا لا يوجد مشكله لدى
السلطات الاوكرانيه من التصريح بهذه
العمليات في شبه جزيره القرم لانها
تعتبرها ارض اوكرانيه محتله وهي هدف مشروع
ايضا بخصوص جسر القرم لانه تعتبر انه خط
امداد رئيسي ودعم لوجستي للجيش الروسي
وبالتالي استهدافه مشروع بالنسبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه وفي مناسبات كثيره رئيس
المخابرات كان قد تحدث ورئيس الامن
الداخلي للتحدث عن انه يعني استهدف لكن لن
يعطي تفاصيل واتحدث طبعا عن استهدافه
السابق في تموز الماضي عامر لافي من نور
الدين الدغير من دنيا شكرا جزيلا لكما